and to
everybody's watching as well for being
them waiting
anyway gotta play faster gotta play
better
we're back with uh the scandinavian
and i got a
little new surprise there i'm going
queen e6
and queen g6 something i thought up
yesterday
um and i would be lying if i said i was
in private
i don't know if i should be but
nevertheless i am
here it feels like i got a good position
uh lots of space in the center
and now i'm gonna try and start an
attack
there we go so
g5 coming up next
wow b6
yeah it's not too stupid
a b he goes no b5 probably attack with
the bishop then
knight b5 i go a6 a5 i go bishop c5
knight a3
this looks unconvincing
say the list bishop c5
queen d5 i suppose
bishop c3 i want rook e8 don't really
want bishop d4
to to exchange
i kind of say his sack wasn't the
dumbest thing i've ever seen
like i thought his position looked
pretty
unappetizing and now i guess i'm better
but
he does have some semblance of
counter play at the very least and now i
just blundered
knight a5 i kind of go b6 because if
[Music]
yeah that was a shame um anyway he
didn't really
generally see that um
okay guess i should take c3
knight b6 i can go qb8
uh
yeah let me just go e4 here
oh my plan was ed then but then queen f3
is a problem
oh boy once again i'm playing
quite weakly and quite slowly as well
okay let me try queen d4 because i
couldn't allow queen d3 queen b2 i think
queen c2 okay
yeah let me go e.t this
is now very dangerous that's for sure
gotta try and escape but i'm so sure of
time
i'm having some major issues here
and he's straight up out hustling me so
far
okay 25.
better run
that's not great news obviously but
it was hard for me to see anything else
at that point
yeah this is also pretty bad
at least i have some kind of kind of
play
yeah hoping for some animating threads
here
okay set up with h5 coming next
i guess
running then i'm gonna go for g2
oh i'm just playing ways way too slow
at least normal position is good but
situation on the clock is
quite dire okay
complete control on the board but
oh i didn't see that
so tricky
gotta play faster